[Music]
he's got a new children's book out
everything is mama so you would think
that you know in a house full of females
that found is the odd man out
no think again how would you describe
yourself as a dad are one of your
daughters more like you that's very
interesting the four-year-old very you
know listens to me I go ahead don't
touch that when it's hot you're hot okay
we're good and then this baby I go
Franny stay here okay I turn around and
she was like two knives yeah where'd you
get the knives check I got on your
Amazon cut you know you're my Amazon
account and he goes I got a prime you
know I go well that's a good deal four
year old witty and two-year-old Franny
are clearly adorable handfuls who don't
even blink twice watching daddy do is
Tonight Show think they've seen me
dressed as a 15 year old girl kind of
like yeah that's what dad does the girls
are also the inspiration behind his
second children's book everything is
mama you got to do your voices when you
read them can you give us a sample of
some of the voices that you kind of
throw out there it's hot mama wanna go
to bed
all right I'll let mom know that's one
of the voices I tell you it's gives you
all the range of as much all the feels
feel feel the feels feel and feels
that's what this is all about Jimmy also
feels for the parents who want to keep
bedtime routines quick book is short
enough so that you can read the book and
just get the hell out of the bedroom I
really want to ask you about your sort
of epic bromance with Justin Timberlake
yeah you guys what makes him the perfect
romance it's just a good guy very
creative
I got a 10-2 bike for my birthday and we
never use it and Justin comes over and
you go let's go all right it I go wanna
go bro bike is like bro biking let's do
it bro you just have a good time in this
tool around you know who knows the
adventures we're gonna know what's gonna
happen
[Music]